so the other day i actually had to have
very minor surgery to remove something
very very nasty inside my neck i'm sure
you can see the stitches still inside my
neck
and on that basis i really wanted to
create something this week that's a
little bit gory a little bit graphic so
i thought squid game was the perfect
tutorial
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk all things architecture and
technology today we're focusing on the
netflix phenomenon squid game i've
watched it in full from start to finish
it is incredible i really didn't think
i'd enjoy the show especially being
dubbed but it was incredible from start
to finish so today i wanted to focus on
squid game and focus on the red light
green light game on that very first
episode that really really hooked you
into that series and made you think the
world is actually a really crazy place
today i'm actually going to teach you
exactly how to recreate that environment
so that you can create your own 3d
models 3d renders do whatever you want
with this information to actually create
some really really cool content so
without me talking too much more let's
turn around to these two screens and get
started with today's tutorial okay so as
you can see i've got twin motion
completely open with the squid games red
light green light modeled directly in
here now i will point out that the
henchman and the actual doll itself are
downloaded directly and i will leave
links down below i didn't create these
two characters here they are downloaded
to make this tutorial very very simple
but everything else that you see here
has been modeled and created either via
the use of photoshop or twin motion so
we're keeping it very very simple and
very very generic so if i fly around
relatively quickly you'll see that we
have those extremely high 10 meter high
walls we have that nasty tree behind the
doll and we have our two henchmen on the
left and right of the doll as well as
our creepy little hut in the background
so the fundamentals of this is very
simple and it's very very easy to create
we can do this in a matter of minutes
i'm going to keep the tutorial very
quick and very brief show you exactly
how i did this let's go file new scene
and let's start from scratch so note
we're not going to save absolutely
anything the first fundamental basics
are to remove the background and change
the sky so if we come down here into
settings go to location and change our
background here from cd to none then we
can also come back into settings go to
our weather and introduce a couple
clouds as we best see fit now obviously
there's nothing happening in this scene
at the moment there is basically just a
blank empty shell which is perfect for
us to create our scene straight out of
squid game so i have saved the squid
game guard and the squid game doll
directly into my user library so we
don't have to go through that process
again but basically it was import import
open find our fbx file click open and
import that directly into our scene i'm
going to start by introducing the scary
doll into our scene right there
and then actually placing her
straight on the ground so she isn't
floating in the middle of the air next
i'm going to introduce two of our squid
guards directly next to our doll
and making this scene really come to
life now as you can tell these
characters are the fundamental
essentials in this whole design
everything else comes together
relatively simply and relatively quickly
now to create that tree behind our dog
we want to come into our trees and we
want to search for a tree that is
relatively similar to what was on the
show
if you saw the original show you'd see
that the tree branches actually fall
down instead of going up too much so
let's select this red oak for example
clicking on it and changing the season
to winter you'll see that it's quite
similar to the tree behind her so if we
just increase the size of that tree just
so slightly
so it looks just as creepy just as
realistic on netflix next we want to
create the scene around her and this is
where we start introducing a secondary
program to actually create the scene we
need so if we come back all the way into
our library go to our objects and go
primitive
we can introduce our box which is 10
meters by 10 meters so clicking escape
let's place our box directly behind
our doll let's make that five times
longer so it's
about 50 meters wide and 10 meters tall
if we fly up a little bit you'll see
it's 10 meters deep as well but that's
not too important for us at the moment
next we're going to hold shift rotate
that 90 degrees and make sure we make a
copy
to be able to then move our secondary
box all the way across
line it up corner to corner next we're
going to hold shift again pulling our
secondary box all the way across lining
up our corners creating a copy and doing
the same thing to close in that
environment so now we have our four
boxes created we've basically created
that entry that our contestants walk
into from squid game and they come
directly into this
creepy doll with a couple of henchmen
standing beside her as well so if we
rotate some of our henchmen we can start
to see
that realistic looking
scene directly from netflix next we want
to change the material of the ground so
if we come to material we go to ground
we go nature and let's change that to
something like rocky dirt so it is quite
harsh and quite textured finally we want
to introduce that red line and that will
be basically all of our elements from
twin motion
so if we come back into our objects go
to our primitives and go box one meter
by one meter introducing that anywhere
for the time being tabbing through
and reducing that 0.05 0.1
and extending that
10 times and 10 times wider so we want
that to go through both sides of our box
so we can create the finish line
again we're going to reduce the depth of
this by another
.5.5 to make it a really skinny line
put it right near our henchman
and change the overall color from white
to a nice finish line red
again let's double that make that a
little bit thicker and place it in front
of our henchmen so now as you can see we
have four bounding boxes around our doll
and our henchman our one large tree in
the center and our red line that is the
finish for all the contestants if you're
enjoying the video so far make sure you
check out the links down below there is
some really good content in each one of
those links for example there is a great
checklist for all of your architecture
working drawing construction
documentation as well as a discord group
chat with professional students and
everybody in the architecture industry
from around the world that is
continuously helping each other grow my
archicad files and twin motion files are
available to download as well via the
patreon link down below the discord chat
so if you do want a copy of anything
that i create for youtube it is
available via patreon now to create the
background of this scene i've actually
gone into photoshop and done a little
bit of photo manipulation so as you can
see here i've photoshopped these
little huts that we saw on the show
directly in to this grass here so if we
go file new i've set up the settings by
going to centimeters going width is
going to be 100 height is going to be
400 and then clicking create now i've
done that incorrectly so i'm just going
to go image image rotation rotate 90
degrees to give us the foundation of
what we're looking for now we obviously
want to find this background which is
just directly off google it's a free
image so what i've done is gone to
google and searched for dry
grass
background go onto my images and try to
find something that would be really good
for that image after a little bit of
searching i managed to find this image
here which i thought was relatively good
and relatively simple to edit so we've
just gone copy and pasted that directly
in what we want to do then is press
control t
holding our alt button we can increase
the size of that
to the maximum size we possibly can next
holding alt again i've copied it all the
way across aligned it command t and
rotate it horizontally so it aligns
perfectly and duplicate it over to the
other side as well so now as you can see
it's a very clear distinction in the sky
that we've repeated this pattern but
overall in the actual grass itself it
isn't too bad it isn't too horrendous so
now i'm going to hold shift and select
all of these down below then press ctrl
e to merge them all into one file now i
do this so i can simply replace the sky
in this whole process if you've never
done a sky replacement in photoshop it
is incredibly easy with the latest
update you simply go to edit
sky replacement let photoshop do its
thing in the background as it creates
that replacement so i've just selected
the generic sky it'll quickly and easily
replace that whole scene next all i do
is click ok
sky replacement again shifting all of
them command control e all of them
merges them down into one single layer
now if you notice on the show that there
are two different types of backgrounds
on the left and right hand side there is
this image without the huts and on the
front and back there is the huts
themselves so we'll just go ctrl shift s
and we can save a left and right png
i've already done it so i'm just going
to save over them go replace yes largest
file possible please now that saves
we're going to come back in to google
and we're going to go squid game
red light green light scene go back to
our images find a good red light green
light scene where we can see that
background hut so right click copy image
come back into photoshop wait for that
to finish loading okay so now we paste
our image as you can see it is
absolutely tiny so again command t or
ctrl t depending on the system you're on
expanding it by holding the alt button
to keep it in proportion
and then simply just cutting out our
little hut over here so by using our
lasso tool we can go around the hut ctrl
c ctrl shift v paste it in the same
place
and we can delete our layer below
next you'll see that we've cut off a
little bit of our corner of our heart so
let's just simply copy and paste half of
this hut
over pressing command t reflecting it or
flipping it horizontally aligning it
with where it needs to be
pressing okay and then tapping our
eraser tool
right clicking to be able to
introduce our eraser and just making
sure that looks a little bit nicer
now we have our one hut created and on
the show it sits roughly
about here and it is relatively small at
the same time it is not overly large we
do again then want to change our razor
to a little bit of a softer brush
get rid of all of this yellow dry tall
grass that is originally from the show
so we can introduce our own grass
overlapping over it so it looks like
that hut is sitting in our tall grass
copying and pasting it across by holding
the alt button controller command t to
make it a little bit smaller and moving
it into the distance
to give it a bit of perspective and
depth even though it is meant to be a
very flat 2d image finally shift click
them all command e
control shift s
and we can replace it with our rear
image here so save and yes okay now that
all those images are saved we can go
back into twin motion come all the way
back go to our objects pick a decal
doesn't matter which decal we click
so let's just pick a zebra crossing for
the purposes of this select on our
crossing go to texture
open and replace that with our rear
texture as you can see it'll pop up
relatively out of proportion so we're
going to go into size more we're going
to scale that four times and we're going
to scale that i believe to
20 times is perfect
if i zoom out a little bit we can then
position that
exactly as we need so let's just move
that the tiniest bit up so it covers the
top of our building
and keeps sliding across
there we go so now we have our building
in the background
and all we need to do is repeat that
step for the remaining walls and there
we have it our red light green light
seen completely manufactured in record
time simply using twin motion
some incredibly detailed characters that
we've been able to download online and a
little bit of creative photoshop once
you've completed all these steps you can
go ahead and export all sorts of
different images little videos you can
use this content basically however you
want to create whatever you want with
this incredible realistic squid games
recreation of the red light green light
game anyway that's all for me today guys
a very short very quick tutorial on how
you can create your very own squid game
in a matter of minutes if you enjoyed
the video please make sure you hit that
like button down below as well as the
subscribe button i'm feeling a little
bit under the weather today from the
stitches and from all the medication to
keep me going strong but i am still
putting in the hard yards to make sure i
bring you guys one video every single
week every single monday so like always
i will see you next monday